[Musique]
sur et si tu savais pas quel il s'agit
6 500 sommes d'accord mais tout de même
en acquitter les autres choses nous
avons notre belle gastronomie n'est ce
pas charles vérité bonjour la question
je suis à goûter mérité au jour ce qu'il
ya beaucoup de choses là c'est
magnifique habits ça sent déjà bon
façades et jardins et bien aujourd'hui
nous allons faire un froid puisque c'est
l'été nous allons faire un coup farcies
ou des coûts farsi et une salade de
gésiers sa seconde cette saison
ça se jouera cette saison alors nous
allons prendre un canard qui a la tête
coupée c'est à dire il est prêt pour
farcir le prêt pour désosser pour le
farcir alors lie alors c'est comme ça
c'est évidemment
alors on va leur tournée et on va
enlever toute la peau ça en essayant de
ne pas déchirer parce que pour déchirer
de tout instauré pour qu'on puisse se
faire mais c'est très facile d'aller
voir la non mais tout le monde y réussir
dans vos émissions et puis ça a l'air
toujours facile et puis quand j'essaie
de le faire
c'est très content mais n'a regardé ça
s'est fait tout seul
la voilà vous avez vidé les avait sortis
donc le lobby de l'atome
qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant bon
alors maintenant pour que la farce
viennent on va le lier à la petite
extrémités alors il est peut trier au
delà des rêves où on veut mais il faut
faire les terrasses en dur ça se voit la
série prend un autre un autre demain
entre notre mieux je coupe des coupes
on a beaucoup payé par d'entendre très
bien sans les doigts très bien et là je
retourne mon cou voilà ce que ça donne
et maintenant on va faire la farce et
qu'est ce qu'on mesure l'effort à ont
mis tout ce qui se trouve là c'est à
dire le lieu pour installer 2 oignons de
l'oignon de roches à l'autre de l'ail du
persil et les ailerons du canard c'est à
dire c'est la partie de rêve évidemment
où se trouvait le magret le magret nous
n'avons sorti et comme il n'y a pas de
perte dans un canard
chaabi il reste ce côté cette partie là
nous en servons c'est la chair alors là
ya du bon [ __ ] ya du gras et ses
délicieux pour faire cette farce alors
la viande lancé cette viande la beauce
ainsi des sas et les ailerons c'est les
éléphants mais cette union ne sais quoi
là c'est pourquoi on aurait avancé
c'est moi qui ai commencé à dépiauter
les éléments a cédé 0 voilà voilà non
car c'est ça alors on fait comme ça
c'est comme ça et on l'a mis dans
mâchoire après voyez-vous fait le
dernier
attention aux doigts voilà il faut que
ce soit chez faire un car même un oui
parce que vous allez voir pourquoi par
la suite laissant ce soin hfr oui parce
qu'il ya plusieurs aussi plusieurs
grains la dame aux lunettes non c'est la
3 alors c'est la relance et le plus de
fermes
c'est le plus frais plus fort pour le
plus fort le plus fermé c'est parce que
le pur et c'est presque oui oui il faut
pas qu'ils ne seront pas plus fréquent
mais maintenant faire oui c'est la plus
fine et cela est apprécié ces cinq ans
et plus et doivent se restaurent joly là
on a bientôt fini je vais mettre un
petit peu de persil quand même répondu
merci robe plus cher adam la ffr que je
pense que c'est quand même il faut la
pratiquer un il faut être gourmand je le
dis je le redis oui il faut être
gourmands curieux la mode à l'autre à
kiev il y en a ils voudront pas le faire
c'est grand chose maintenant
alors là il ya l'oignon l'échalote l'ail
le persil et la viande est alors
maintenant c'est depuis le but d aulas
mais le meilleur vous allez voir
maintenant on va mettre là apparemment
gabonais qui sort et voilà alors que
même essuyé les mains sales et s'est pas
autant que moi je suis je suis que je
suis que le naïf
pas trop pas trop bas alors on va
prendre ceci je laime le mettre là et
alors là je vais mélanger le tout mais
moi je mélange le tout avec les mairies
on mélange de tous et pas très
appétissant mais pourtant ça se fait
comme ça mais c'est comme ça c'est le
farsi j'ai pas un plâtre et est très
bien pour faire sa promo ça déborde
on mélange bien farce
alors maintenant reste le foie alors 2-1
alors est deux fois celle qui fait toute
la différence
voilà alors le fond on ne va pas lâcher
bien sûr c'est le foie de canard à
leucan deux fois on va le couper en
tranches voyez-vous lab se boursoufle
ils sont jolis là qu'on va découvrir la
mer parce que le fois plus on lâche
faire plus s'il faut il s'en vend grèce
puisse traiter les petits morceaux
- vous avez de 2,2 fois plus vous avez
de grèce cette étrange je suis assez
épaisse
alors on va le couper en dés là on va
reprendre là et nous allons couper en
dés voilà là et nous allons le mettre là
pour passer à la moulinette
ah non non non non voilà donc le produit
passe par le poids il passe par la
moulinette
mais si des crimes et que les
téléspectateurs peuvent pas se rendre
compte ce que ça sent très bon ça sent
très bon sens et ça sent très très bon
et là c'est carrément fan de hip hop et
rap et bien sûr en fête du mascaret il
faut que ça très relevé parce que la vie
on y arrive cela vient de fabienne
éparses à lait avarié arrière le voyage
à rome et viérin parce que l'on se
sépare relever ces fichiers
c'est tous les coins oui mais pas trop
voir même nom quand même il faut pas
tirer la langue à canton de marge non là
mais apparemment là je pense ça devrait
aller
alors maintenant devoir en secourir les
coups des coups alors que nous avons
ficelés vide et nous allons à remplir
voyez les voir la force
la farce et les morceaux de foie en
quarts et la politique pas de nom pas de
bateau du tout et regarder non la vienne
plaire mais pas trop pourquoi puisqu'on
doit quand même on à coudre à la coudre
c'est ta journée la caravane elle
cuisinier les couturières photo
savoir-faire là normalement y en a c'est
un peu plus qu'un soupçon un peu de
froid là il ya sera pour nous alors on
va bien alors on va faire un ourlet on
va rabattre sur le petit peu c'est un
joli ou presque alors normal marges et
une aiguille on fait ça avec une
aiguille à ces grosses quand même pas
une petite aiguille or de faire des
ourlets en fait on est au bout comme
pour coup de nous on est pareil la seule
différence que la vie est quand même
attendre alors si on fait pas en deux
assez important et n'est plus avocat la
foule il faut kudrin et oui parce
qu'autrement sur le coup pas quand on va
cuire dans notre cas c'est là je crois
aussi leur silence à se déchirer sa
déchirure oui bon voilà alors ce coup
qui est cousu qui remplit quelques-unes
nous allons le mettre dans un chaudron
qui remplit de graisse de canard et le
faire cuire une heure de temps une lune
quand ça commence à bouger
si si il va être un peu plus petit mais
il n'en restera chasser l'armée traque
là on va mettre plus d'un pompier en
général on peut remettre crois que cela
le résultat non seulement le gaz de
traoui c'est la grèce notamment de soie
bouillon
qui aident mais c'est chaud là je
voudrais vous la montrer et aromatisé
l'annoncé d'un gosse de turin agressé
nature là et on va faire maintenir notre
salade annoncé la salle c'est la salade
de gésiers de canard de suzy de canal
alors les gésiers mais voici six bouts
nous les avons pour gagner du temps
couper en lamelles et alors nous allons
prendre le saladier avec de la frise et
alors là ça la ne peut permettre avait
donné tu parles c'est en plus parce que
c'est pas pour ça c'est parce que la
laitue elle tombe facilement oui alors
on fait des siennes alors c'est où la
scarole ou la frisée alors on met la
salade
nous mettons des croûtons aillés nous
allons les mettre dans la poêle qui se
trouve la difficulté un monde
en effet on vous dit non pas du tout mes
blessures venaient à les surveiller
là on va les laisser dorer pendant dix
d'or on va les y naître tous
on va assaisonner la salade on va
commencer la saison n'est là de quoi lui
le vinaigre
de quoi n'importe quoi il faut pas faire
de la saison demain la moins chère et
moins cher c'est pour le nous allons la
ramener
ça c'est une seule population pour
quatre personnes alors là on va mettre
un peu de rien ils sont acculés et
s'enfuit à la grèce
c'est des connards suis au confit sont
conçus et fils et des gésiers confits
alors on va les mettre là voilà pour
cette voie là pendant ce temps on va
surveiller nos coûts tant les canards
gras c'est avant tout sa salade et que
c'est à la fois n'y a pas de calendrier
pour totaliser même constat d'avoir un
autre ça valait bien sympathique nous
attendons plus que déroutant
quand on écoute on sort on brise ça sert
à l'atterrissage je crois que ça va non
aux bravo il vous est pas ce qu
apprendre et faire court ce qui les rend
très bien on va les mettre là
normalement il faudrait qu'ils sont peu
froid mais comment va la manger puis à
froid un peu ça c'est le magret fumé
je vais ce quinté c'est dommage c'était
un magret cru qui est fumé au feu de
bois
c'est à dire corps mais ça on le coupe
en pensionnat et détailler ces
merveilleux et on le fait fumer au cuir
tout doucement en l'air au feu de bois y
est moi je ne sais pas trop bien faire
c'est très dur à faire et c'est très
délicat
alors voilà elle rentre des coupes alors
là dans cette salade chicorée la scarole
la chicorée les croûtons le
mais gésiers et on arrange le dessus
c'est comme ça et on appelle ça le
salaire de composer une salade de
gésiers de canard au magret aussi
botswana ce très beau c'est vrai
décorateur de manger comme du comesa bon
sens voudrait faire jouer tout le temps
mais je coûtais il faut goûter c'est si
c'est pas beau bientôt l'accusé il faut
goûter brillé par ses mots
donc voilà notre salade est prête elle
est belle belle belle on dirait un
tableau tableaux de cézanne c'est
magnifique alors dessus et les désirs
voilà alors c'est de la frisée des
gésiers confits de canard confit des
couteaux à y est revenu à la poêle et
décoré avec des magrets pigot n'est pas
obligé de copenhague comme ça parce que
les couples aixois mère faire là c'est
bon comme ça fait voilà et en décors
avec les magrets fumés de 60 c'est alors
que ce n'est pas scellé mais voilà alors
nos coûts sont cuits sur le scénario il
ya une heure qui cuisent exactement
alors nous allons les sortir
voilà nous allons baisser lens la voilà
nos couples sont dorés sont bien dorés
une heure de cuisson riz qu'ils ont
diminué bien sûr mais pas trop quand
même pas trop là là il reste plutôt la
pole
le grand atout du tout partie de leur
temps à des morceaux découpés en trois
tranches
moi je dois procéder à huy non non non
non non non non la peau la peau est
extra non non non
alors on peut les manger ou chaud mais
comme nous le faisons tous froid et b
nous démarrerons 3 bon alors mérité par
la magie de la télévision
les cous farcis 100 x 3 donc il faut les
couper en images comme ça si on les
présente comme son esprit pop une salade
laitue la salade de gésiers gésiers
l'écoutant elle malgré le temps alors
quand est ce que tu as et ya donc encore
des coups nico qu'il prépare je crois
que c'est une des dernières émissions de
vacances a dit m hélas ils ont bien de
la chance tous les téléspectateurs qui
auront vu cette émission
les phillies ont tous deux suivi parce
que on apprend beaucoup de choses
je crois que ça va rendre les gens au
gourmand et gourmet certain puisqu'il
voit les morceaux de foie gras et ça en
attendant alors oui ça c'est un petit
miracle que parce qu'en fait le foie
d'oie ils font pas ils ne forment pas
c'est formidable parce que l'on pourrait
croire que puisant si longtemps pendant
une heure on le verrait plus on les voit
encore choisi la qualité aussi bien
écoutez moi m'a dit et j'ai beaucoup
plus appris la cuisine grâce à ses
émissions que j'ai regardé avant d'être
allés nous votre invité je crois que
tous les téléspectateurs
ravi d'avoir vu la cuisine comme chez
soi quand on l'a fait avec son coeur à
l'étude avec du goût et avec beaucoup
d'expérience à les choses avancent au
revoir charles et merci beaucoup d'avoir
mérité au revoir
[Musique]